[Musique]
ses apparitions se font de plus en plus
rares mais simone veil ancien ministre
de la santé celle qui a défendu et
obtenu le droit à l'avortement a tenu à
être présente pour l'inauguration de
l'ufr des sciences de la santé de
montigny qui porte dorénavant son nom
une ufr des sciences de la santé
autrement dit une université où l'on
enseigne à la fois le médical et le
paramédical première particularité la
seconde cette ufr est implantée dans la
ville et non au sein d'un établissement
hospitalier universitaire comme cela se
voit couramment et ce n'est pas un
hasard
on pense que ça ça permet pour partie de
réseaux des deux traités
les difficultés que l'on a pas former
des professions de santé on pense
peut-être faire soit des maisons de
santé universitaire soit des pôles de
santé qui vont aider des endroits de
soins de premier recours et qui
permettrait peut-être de désengorger un
petit peu les urgences des hôpitaux et
puis de prendre en charge de façon très
universitaire je dirais des malades si
ie tous les étudiants sont formés en
centre ville
si tous les étudiants passent l'ensemble
de leur cursus universitaire à
l'intérieur de l'hôpital
il y a peu de chances pour qu'ils aient
envie d'aller s'installer à l'extérieur
de l'hôpital
et encore moins à l'extérieur des
grandes villes donc c'est évidemment un
enjeu tout à fait important rapprocher
la formation des lieux d'installation à
venir
la lutte contre les déserts médicaux la
ministre présentera prochainement des
mesures dans ce sens
autre application de l'ufr des sciences
de la santé qui a convaincu marisol
touraine la mutualisation des moyens
entre différentes disciplines
dans ce laboratoire par exemple les
chercheurs traite des pathologies liées
à des traumatismes de la moelle osseuse
de la recherche fondamentale avec des
buts appliquer au quotidien quand là
la personne a eu un accident de voiture
ou a subi une atteinte au niveau du
système nerveux central
ça a des conséquences sur sa sexualité
et sa comptine ans donc on travaille sur
des modèles animaux de façon à
comprendre et à pallier éventuellement
dans l'avenir c'est troubles
particuliers en trouvant des médicaments
qui pourraient agir sur la relaxation
delà de la vessie d'une part ou en
interrogeant plus précisément le système
nerveux central de façon à faire des
thérapies novatrices et en particulier
été rapide à base de transferts de
jeunes l'ufr des sciences de la santé
avait été pensé dès 2003 il est situé à
deux pas du centre commercial régional
accueille mille étudiants en première
année et 5000 en totalité les amphis
sont plus adaptées c'est exclusivement
des cours de médecine je pense
contrairement à l'ancienne fac
après moi je trouve un peu moins
chaleureuse c'est plus austère ben est
très sympa les plus proches de la gare
donc c'est plus rapide donc ces
pratiques
en tout c'est ufr compte 125 enseignants
et 18 laboratoires mixtes
[Musique]